une petite caravane rouge mais un grand
voyage voilà ce que propose praliné
gay-para avec de petites histoires de
dix minutes elle vous invite dans sa
petite bulle dans son imaginaire chacun
va où il veut c 5e bien dans la caravane
contrairement aux avions on a une
destination commune et s'ils mangent
propose une histoire et chacun fait le
voyage qui souhaite ou pas en résidence
depuis la saison dernière à guyancourt
praliné gay-para s'inspire de ces
rencontres pour composer sa découverte
du conte remonte elle à ses études en
ethno linguistique cris
j écris
voilà là les oreilles sont bien en face
des trous j'ai fait une thèse sur des
comptes que j'ai collecté au liban au
beau milieu de la guerre civile fin des
années 70 c'est mu années 80 et j'ai
attrapé le virus verbalement
transmissibles incurable et au bout d'un
moment j'en avais plus envie de parler
des comptes tu avais envie de les
raconter voilà pour découvrir les récits
de pralines guépard a rendez vous le 26
octobre à la maison de quartier théodore
monod compte merveilleuse ou fantastique
vous y attendent
[Musique]